how people endure the shelling and
destruction defies belief
Russian Artillery has almost completely
destroyed the town of bakmut
most of the 70 000 people who lived here
have fled
it's even rare to see Ukrainian soldiers
in the open exposed to shelling on the
streets
when we talk about the direction of back
mode
we're talking about the whole front line
they're trying to get into the city from
every direction from the north from the
East and the South
the intensification the shelling of
bakmut is obvious Russian forces are
about a kilometer in that direction
the
the Ukrainian military is scared now
that because Russian forces have made
such great gains around solidar in the
north they're now trying to completely
encircle the city
as we walk back up the street more
rounds explode close by
foreign
We Begin filming and two more come in
around 100 yards away
We Run for Cover skin in here
our camera on the car dashboard captured
the moment two of what's believed to
have been 120 millimeter mortars slammed
into a residential building across the
street the force of the blast broke the
windscreen
thank you
it's a similar story on the other side
of town Ukrainian Army are moving to
push back a Russian advance from the
southeast
the situation is quite intense all
around bakmut we have information that
the Russians have sent reinforcements
toward the city
Ukrainian artillery fires from nearby
fields
the battle for Bahamut is intensifying
by the day
Charles Trafford Al Jazeera
people in the central Ukrainian city of
danipro have paid tribute to the victims
of a Russian missile strike they laid
wreaths and placed candles at the
destroyed apartment building at least 40
people were killed the mayor says there
is little chance any more survivors will
be found
the UN Human Rights Commission says 7
000 civilians have been killed in
Ukraine since the beginning of the war
let's go straight to Natasha Butler who
is live for us in Kiev Natasha those are
pretty Grim statistics aren't they
green statistics and look just another
sobering reminder of the toll that this
war is taking on ordinary people more
than 7
000 civilians say the UN have been
killed in this war so far that includes
children it includes uh teenagers also
more than 11 000 people have been uh
injured and what the UN says is that
most of these injuries and most of these
deaths were caused by uh weapons by
artillery uh shelling and air strikes
now the U.N report doesn't attribute
responsibility but there is no doubt in
the minds of most ukrainians that this
is the work of Russian forces Moscow
since it first invaded in February last
year has continued to say that it does
not uh Target civilian infrastructure or
the civilian population but just on
Saturday an 11 meter long ballistic
missile slammed into an apartment block
into nepro in central Ukraine the mayor
there says that the hope of finding any
survivors Now is really fading and has
pretty much faded I should say but
dozens of people were killed there
including a 15 year old girl dozens of
people injured in fact uh just on uh
Monday the Sweden that currently has the
head is currently the head of the eu's
rotating presidency has said that what
happened in denipro is surely a war
crime
many thanks for that Natasha Butler
there for us live in Kiev